Steve Bannon had nothing to do with
January 6th he wasn't there he committed
no crime but that didn't stop the
January 6 committee from trying to
destroy him anyway today Bannon was
sentenced to four months in federal
prison at the request of that committee
as Congressman Matt Gates has pointed
out the Department of Justice official
who prosecuted Steve Bannon a man called
Matthew Graves is a partisan Democrat he
was on Joe Biden's domestic policy
Committee in the 2020 campaign and
worked for other Democratic campaigns so
what we're seeing clearly is the
corruption of the rule of law Congress
held Lois Lerner and Eric Holder in
contempt famously but of course they
never spent a day in jail and they were
never going to because they were
faithful Democrats tonight to see Bannon
joins us for his first interview since
his sentencing Stephen thanks so much
for coming on site do you agree with
Matt Gates that this is partisan
that's 100 I mean the whole justice
department under Merrick Garland has
become radically partisan and I think
that's after we win on November 8th to
deliver this crushing blow against the
Democratic party this regime Tucker I
strongly believe you'll see mayor
Garland impeached next year by the new
Congress I certainly hope so people who
say four months in prison is not a big
deal had ever been to a prison it is a
big deal how are you going to respond to
this do you plan to submit well
well we get well number one we have the
judge laid out today a number of areas
of appeal I've got a great legal team my
legal team is working on the appeals
right now we've got uh appeals on you
know use of attorney uh separation of
powers executive privilege the structure
of the of the uh January 6th committee
so we've got a lot of appeals it'll work
through the appeals process and so this
is all my sentencing is all pending the
uh the appeals process and we'll work
through it like I said on your show the
first time at the end of the day I got
to go to prison by this illegitimate
regime hey I I respect what the judge
did today I'm prepared to do it but we
got a long appeals process
what do you think this says about our
system more broadly however I mean
you're saying that you're being sent to
prison
because you advised Donald Trump
politically I mean that doesn't sound
like a free country where something like
that could happen
it's not free right now you see this in
it whether it's the FBI rolling up uh
individuals praying in front of abortion
centers or designating parents going to
parents rights at the school board
meetings for parents rights as domestic
terrorists the justice department is
completely and totally out of control
and the FBI is out of control that's why
I'm a big believer in defund the FBI use
the Appropriations process to defund
both these apparatuses until they come
to the table we start cleaning up the
Rat's Nest I think the only way you're
going to do it is you got to start at
the top we got to impeach Rey and we're
going to Peach Merrick Garland after
full investigations I think mayor
Garland could be impeached on the
southern border I think you can impeach
but what he's trying to do to these
parents uh the parents Rights Movement I
think that Mary Garland will be
impeached next year by the new Congress
one of the reasons that our system has
become partisan in the rule of law is
evaporating because no one's pushing
back against it are you satisfied with
the response from elected Republicans to
what's happened to you is anyone
sticking up for you do you think
I think it's fine and look look elected
Republicans what they need to do now is
focus on the 8th of November Tucker
there's no substitute for victory we
have a very good opportunity here to
shatter the Democratic party as a
national political institution from
school boards to state legislatures to
attorney general secretaries of state to
take the house by 40 or 50 seats and
maybe take the Senate by four or five
seats to meet elected officials right
now should just focus on winning and
winning with the biggest at the biggest
wave we can I I I I can do this myself
with my lawyers I don't need Republicans
have my back what I want Republicans to
do is in the new Congress is to focus on
cleaning out the Rat's Nest at doj and
clean up The Rat's Nest of the FBI
if your lowest learner or your Eric
Holder both of whom committed from my
read actual crimes against the country
unlike you you have not been accused
even of doing that and both of them
skated on contempt charges
do you think they're ashamed do they see
the double standard has either one
reached out to you to commiserate with
you I'm serious like on a human level
no look as you know the city is so
partisan this process now is so partisan
and they are some of the most partisan
people especially Eric Holder Eric
Holder is the hatchet man for Obama so
no they did and by the way I wouldn't
want him to right now hey this is an
unbridgeable Gap you have the
Republicans and the mega forces on one
side you have these radical Democrats
another you see this is not rule of law
it's like a Banana Republic you can't
compromise in this there's no substitute
for victory we have to win massively on
the eighth and then this new Congress
has to really go and enforce the rule of
law and the way you're forced to rule of
law is start serious investigations not
political serious investigations Tucker
and after those investigations start
bringing articles of impeachment and
throw these bums out whether it's my
Yorkers at DHS or gone with the attorney
general and who knows where it ends
yeah who knows where it ends is Right
Steve Bannon good luck I'd be you don't
seem worried I'd be worried uh if I were
you you're a brave man and I appreciate
you're coming on that word thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight